in a sense apex legends is not the same
game that we reviewed back in february
2019.
between new characters maps features and
regular seasonal content
respawn has transformed its battle
royale into something greater and yet
despite these adjustments the core of
apex legends remains intact
the formula that made apex legends work
so well back when it first
launched hasn't changed over two years
later
all of which is to say apex legends is
still really fun and worth jumping into
if you haven't yet and now you're able
to do so
on nintendo switch but just because you
can play apex legends on switch
does not mean you should
to the credit of developer panic button
the switch port does
function i've only had one crash in my
five hours with the game so far
and the switch rebooted the game fast
enough for me to rejoin my squad without
fuss but it feels like the switch is
barely making it work on switch apex
legends targets 720p
resolution while docked and 576p in
handheld
and though the 720p sounds pretty good
the switch port seemingly manages to
reach those resolutions only by
compromising on graphical detail
draw distance and the speed at which
assets are loaded
and on top of that though the switch
port targets 30 frames per second
you can tell that it dips below that
that's all a very technical way of
saying that apex legends looks muddied
on switch
whether docked or in handheld especially
in comparison to playing on other
systems
now on a surface level this just means
the switch port is less pretty
but in a more substantial way these
drawbacks and resolution and frame rate
put you at a disadvantage when you're
fighting against someone who's playing
on
any other system because on switch it's
harder to see people from farther away
and it's more difficult to discern
individual bullets
in a fast-paced battle royale like apex
legends knowledge is power and the
ability to make split-second decisions
with the information you have
can be paramount for success and that's
just harder to do on switch which can
lead to frustrating losses when you're
put into a match with xbox playstation
or pc
players and on switch where the frame
rate regularly fluctuates below 30 fps
it can prove difficult to land shots
with firearms that rely on precision
because your image isn't keeping pace to
accurately track
enemy movements and animations making it
more difficult to line up shots
this is less of a problem at close range
where pinpoint precision matters less
and tracking targets
is easier and granted apex legends meta
does naturally skew towards close range
weapons like shotguns
so you'll probably be regularly fighting
up close anyway
but there are situations where a mid to
long range semi-automatic weapon is
preferable
on switch where i'm not really afforded
that option it seems like there's an
unfair advantage to anyone else in the
match who's playing on xbox playstation
or pc
thankfully you can disable crossplay but
that does limit you
the pool of players you'll be able to
match with will be significantly smaller
increasing the likelihood that the game
may struggle to connect you to similarly
skilled players
and of course if your friends are
already playing on other platforms
turning off crossplay means you can't
team up with them so although disabling
crossplay is an
option it isn't a satisfying solution to
the overarching problem
that the switch just isn't the ideal way
to play apex legends
given the fast-paced nature of apex
legends fights it can also be a bit of a
struggle to play with the switch's
joy-con controllers
the analog sticks proved to be a
frustrating hassle for the game's
competitive
demands especially in handheld mode the
motion controls do not help but
thankfully you can turn those off
my enjoyment of the switch port improved
immensely once i started using a proper
gamepad controller and on that note i
did have moments of fun
playing apex legends on switch panic
button has managed to take a game that i
love
and make it work just well enough on
nintendo's hybrid console
i don't want to keep playing it on
switch with its many technical
concessions
but this board is a decent last resort
for folks who want to get into apex
legends
and only own a nintendo switch just know
that you're signing up for something
less than ideal
foreign